When you want to just try an idea out in BlueJ, you have a couple options to
start. One is to open the test prog BlueJ project that we made for you. It's in
the files for lesson 1. The other option is to make a new project using BlueJ.
To open the test prog project, open up BlueJ, click the Project menu, and then
from the drop down select Open Project. Use the window that pops up to navigate
to wear ever the lesson 1 code is. Double click, and open Testprog. It should
look something like this. If you right click, you can open the editor. And then
you have a main method all set up and ready to go for you where you can put
whatever code you want to try out. If instead of using the test project that we
made for you, you want to make a new project. You would go to the same Project
menu, select New Project. And then give it a name. Some examples are compiler
runtime, errors, hello, whatever your project is going to be about. I'll just
call this one a new project. Now I close whatever project I had open before and
I can see my new project. Before I can write code in it, though, I have to
click New Class. And then come up with a name. I'll just call this one Testing
An Idea for now. Now you edit this the same way you always would. Open Editor,
and there's a lot of stuff in here. I always just delete it. Except for the
class definition. And then add back whatever code I need to try out the thing I
want to try. Again, you can put whatever code you want in here. Now that you've
seen how to make a new testing project, let's put that skill to use. We're
going to try out some code.